so people keep saying that this cut of
Animation from the gear 5 episode is
done through Ai and is going to drive me
into an early grave the cut was animated
by the shinya ohira an absolute colossal
legend in the animation industry making
his unique mark on serieses such as
Akira Ghost in the Shell Spirited Away
Kill Bill to name but a few and honestly
his inclusion on this episode feels
pretty Monumental in and of itself given
that he usually sticks to either
full-blown movies or more experimental
Niche TV anime like Space Dandy having
him appear on something as big and
popular as one piece and create such an
incredible stylistically Rich cut for
gear 5 well it really is an artistic
gift of the highest magnitude and to
have people think that this Mastercraft
is a work of some mindless AI art gen
makes me want to commit crimes I can't
talk about on this app